c'est sur mulhouse où il y a le nombre
le plus important de copropriétés en
difficulté fragile en très grande
difficulté beaucoup de dispositifs
existent au niveau national ces
initiatives copro au niveau régional
initiative qu'aux professionnels au
niveau du département en année des
dispositifs et aussi au niveau
intercommunal et parmi les copropriétés
fragile il y à la tour de l'europe
le logement est un levier important pour
le développement d'un territoire et son
attractivité
toutes les politiques publiques
aujourd'hui l'ont compris et notamment
la question des copropriétés en
difficulté parce que là la copropriété
quand elle est en difficulté c'est tout
le territoire qu'il est au département
nous avons porté il ya quelques années
le tupac le plan opérationnel d'action
et de prévention de et de lutte contre
les l'écho profiter en difficulté ce
pour pâques a permis à cette copropriété
dans laquelle nous sommes aujourd'hui la
copropriété dunkerque de bénéficier des
deux jurys dictée par l'adil et de
bénéficier des aides
aujourd'hui cette aide va dans le bon
sens va dans le bon sens et a permis de
solliciter donc des moyens de l'anah du
moyen de procivis pour refaire le
chauffage dans cette copropriété aussi
donc cette copropriété va bénéficier
d'un autre outil que nous avons mis en
place en partenariat avec appuie cette
fois ci est toujours là dit il mais pour
un accompagnement social
comme vous le savez les les
contre-vérités quand ils sont en
difficulté c'est souvent pour des
raisons de financement de travaux et
dans ces copropriétés souvent il y à des
ménages qui sont très modestes notamment
les petites les retraités avec des
petites retraites et c'est pour ça qu'il
faut cet accompagnement social